une production du studio sfr
vient venu au sans filtre présentée par
chris miller podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos habitudes a dit si tu
peux acheter avec moins de plantes on
est extrêmement heureux d'annoncer la
continuité notre partenariat avec keis
mis en fait qu'ils renouvellent leur
partenariat tellement les la réponse a
été bonne donc si vous voulez changer
votre caisse de cela à votre caisse
d'ordinateurs vos charges etc etc on a
un code promo pour vous qui le sf 15
pour 15 % de rabais sur les produits
qu'ils me pia et revient tout juste de
lancer leur nouvelle collection
d'automne fait qu'aller voir les
nouveaux design d'automne d'une tunique
pays qui sont incroyables fait que
regarder le dos de votre élan c'est le
temps de changer de caisse
[Musique]
cette semaine on a reçu est si c'est lui
qui dit tout buzz qui spécialisée
principalement dans maquillage conseils
maquillage ou et view de produits et
cetera entre en compte et en fait ce
sont histoire ses débuts avec sa chaîne
youtube comment ça a pris des
proportions incroyables et aussi comment
ça se voit dans l'avenir quand elle se
projette et aussi léa de raconter un peu
plus l'île s'enfonce contreverse keller
qu'elle pu vivre de sa carrière de
youtube heures mais aussi d'éthique
autour d'eux des demandes débit
cosmétiques ce soir intéressant on la
remercie vraiment d'être venu nous voir
à notre podcast et on a vraiment un
signe la conversation que tourné autour
de la nécessité créer des produits qui
existent déjà mais ton ouais c'est
l'espèce de tendance les deux lancers de
la marche le caecum de réfléchir à
exclure quelqu'un a vraiment ce que
c'est vraiment un plus value pour
quelqu'un si chanceux
nous expliquer que c'est une des raisons
pourquoi le jamais fait de ligne de
cosmétiques allemand ce qui se disait ça
existe déjà mais trop
respect respect diot qu'est ce que fait
qu'avant on va l'écouter on va les
remercier en fait de commencer mon
paquet monique le podcast est présenté
par sonia enhco quitte une marque de
bougies et de produits de bien être
ils y ont des files des fragrances
pardon vraiment unique vous retrouverez
nulle part ailleurs les combinaisons
devront vraiment spécial et leurs potes
sont fait dans le respect de
l'environnement les ingrédients sont de
qualité supérieure et l'entreprise est
fondée et dirigée par des femmes au
québec
en fait les produits aussi sont fait 100
% au québec dont on consomme notre local
c'est à partir de ce seuil à 100%
naturel et en plus c'est sa cruauté
animale et certifié des gannes on aime
ces sources un peu le podcast le
certifier vegan mois les produits sur ya
une couche d acheter des jeunes qui nous
renvoie pour qu'on en parle sur le
podcast parce que j'adore leur fragrance
en fait moi que comme tu le sais je
prend des bains quand je prends des
banques fermées lumières je mets une
petite bougie chouïan co puis c'est vrai
que c'est ce
wave exact mais là je me mets de la
mosquée je me d'ollone du 1er au 30
septembre toutes les chandelles serial
et l'est qui vont être pendus ont donné
un petit déjeuner complet au club des
petits déjeuners
qui est un organisme extraordinaire lyon
une nouvelle boutique dans le district
pignon sur rue au dix30 pis aller 7
septembre ils vont lancer leur
collection d'automne vous le savez les
odeurs d'automne c'est des odeurs très
réconfortante c'est le point de rentrer
chez vous que ça c'est un petit peu elle
citrouilles août et tous ces odeurs
l'aude où il entend les fantômes hors
promo pour vous sans fil 20% de rabais
sur tous les achats de soya qu'on fait
que procure et douceur c'est vraiment
d'abord le votre caf est présenté par
police lui qui présente un nouveau
produit le couvre maintenant back to
school en ce moment on est en période on
retourne à l'école il fait chaud le
couvre matelots ce qui fait c'est qu'ils
protègent mattei 100% imperméable fac il
importe quelle sorte d'éclaboussures ça
soit l'ex la toile assurer coûte la
canicule ce soit d'autres fluides
corporels ou non corporelle ça peut-être
matt l'on sait pas ce qui peut arriver
dans un lycée important protéger leurs
matelas mais la fibre mince et
imperméables et super reste il respire
ans à l'évacuer l'humidité mais tout en
restant super pas aérer donc c'est
vraiment agréable pour vous et pour
votre matelas et pour éviter les petits
bouts et en plus de cela le couvre lit
imperméable et permet de réduire les
allergies parce que ça crée une surface
qui vient séparer votre corps et votre
matelas donc ouais ce qu'on sait que des
bactéries des acariens d'une cause des
allergies mais ça s'appelle une barrière
protectrice pour favoriser votre sommeil
moi je sais que personnellement h d'un
grand
allergique dans vie à plein d'affaires
puis définitivement je vais me procurer
le couvre lit pour les slips en un code
promo pour vous qui est le sf 15 pour 15
% de rabais sur tous vos achats polly
peck kirk pauvres et
pour vrai honnêtement fort il ya huit
ans reuters le sommeil c'est la chose la
plus importante à optimiser avant toute
chose faite c'est la dengue point vestri
avant d'investir dans l'emprunt de
cochonneries investi dans un bon matelas
dans ce stock police l'ait fait merci
pour les scripts merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va merci d'être là on va juste
continuer sa conversation qu'on avait
avant d'entendre ce que dans le fond tu
parlais c'est ça qu'il y avait eu
mais on avait parlé du truc ce site elle
s'appelait l'avant c'est un constructeur
fait qu'ils étaient c'est sur youtube
tout sur instagram c'est surtout
instagram toujours un truc pour la
victoire semblait vraiment surtout super
cool dessus
pour
longtemps je les trouvais que mon linge
était propre à prix avec du recul je
pourrais dire que le j'aurais dû faire
aussi le test mettons laver mon linge
sans savon
pas la même
façon je ne savait pas à ce moment là je
savais pas non plus qui est dans le
temps c'était maman dion qui en avait
fait la promotion et son sadate le
faites moi j'ai plus qu'en connaissance
de ce puits les autres gens qui en
parlent et non plus évidemment vu qu'on
était tout assez jeune mais d'appeler
boule magique ça se vendait chez walmart
le testing l'entv les choses comme ça je
savais déjà été démontré que c'était
beau et efficace pour vrai ces produits
là mais moi je manque de bateaux le cema
m'a dit ok
je connaissais pas mais c'est plus comme
aimait à beaune et y en a une ou deux
qui m'ont envoyé des liens et c'est
cette petite stèle alibaba qui est
ouvrier la même boule identique en fait
défaut ministre lui-même photo qui était
volé j'ai vu aussi qu'il y avait une
marque en france qui est elle le même
concept en fait la marque et qui m'avait
approché
une marque québécoise des naissances et
qu'on voulait bien encourager cassandra
et moi une autre et finalement si son
mouvement se rendre compte du genre dès
que j'ai fait le contraire le lendemain
j'ai eu des red flag d2 dès le lendemain
j'ai vite
fait avant la pression un peu parce que
là il voulait qu'on refasse d'hystérie
en dix ans jean-paul la promo va se
terminer vente en 24 heures ben là bas
j'avais comme un doute ça serait pas
vraie piqué reste restreint en promo
comme des faits je pense le lendemain ou
le surlendemain le site est tombé en
panne l'adresse ne fonctionnait plus
mais là j'avais plein d'abonnés qu'il
l'avait acheté ce produit fonctionne
comme au maillot qu'est ce qui se passe
puis c'est quand j'ai vu l'autre site en
france ils étaient identiques fakih est
est copié collé y avait même le
copyright de l'autre marque en france
sur les
cds chapitre faille j'ai envie de faire
un petit encas tandis que oui
oui il ya une à bali en particulier
m'avait aidé d'ailleurs le camp s'est
rendu compte de ça on échange et puis
jetée comme à ces jeunes qui est un peu
sur le coup non pas que j'ai rectifié le
tir les plus vite possible c'est que ça
a l'air tellement de succès que ça à la
errol si j'arrête comme l'équipe écho
aux éco responsable c'est vraiment le
meilleur attention des membres de dire
ça me représente vraiment changer
quelque chose pas quelque chose de
membres nommés comme d'une situation est
arrivé où est ce que je faisais de la
pub pour une balance dans le fond qui
donne pleins de statut puis c'est
vraiment aussi le produit vraiment rock
fonctionne bien et puis moi je
l'utilisent tous les jours si sûr car à
mener j'avais comme trois répétitions
genre qu'il fallait que j'étais en
contrôle déjà les chastes rochelle de
story 2 à 3 mois différentes c'est que
les nouvelles promos aux affaires - puis
le produit était heureux puis quand j'ai
fait la première fois le monde l'ont sup
il y avait pas eu de problème il tout le
monde c'est jared versus est vraiment
cool merci pour le coach c'était genre
20% tester quand même au dessus puis la
deuxième fois de l'est fait j'ai
commencé à voir des messages de gens et
je sais pas m'as balancé où ça fait
trois semaines que les commandes et j'ai
pas de tracking j'ai pas rien
le mot j g comme écrit à combani ce fait
what's up et les autres me disait tu me
répondait vraiment tizié técher plein
répondait faisait on est vraiment des
problèmes de logistique à claques au
vide puis on essaie de rattraper
le tenter puis il a finalement tout le
monde parce que moi j'ai noté tout le
monde qui m'avait écrit qu'elle est
perçue tout le monde qui m'ont écrit on
finit par le recevoir mais genre un mot
art or l'étude pilote le mois il
mondiale ce mois ci c'est le message
pour la troisième le troisième homme je
leur ai juste répondu
je veux pas faire des services sa
clientèle puisse le vote à votre
problème de logistique ma force et moi à
avoir l'air d'un tout croche qui vendre
les stewards à mes abonnés fait que j'ai
fait écoutez je vais pas refaire une
troisième fois même si votre produit est
bon puisque au final tout le monde a
reçu ce qu'ils ont commandés je veux pas
me paraît créé par les abonnés ou est ce
que ceci s'est rendu où j'ai pas de
tracking ça marche pas votre business
marche poppy continue mais il y avait
commencé et c'est quand même mais ce
mouton modja regarder di pour bi la
confiance des gens le mois sa peau était
seulement dont je sais je me doutais en
fait fait qu'elle ait jamais recevoir le
produit ou très en retard puis il ya les
aussi s'appuyer sur les fixes et à la
copie - mais non il y en a qui n'ont su
genre sept mois plus tard le mélange
suivante humain oui je pense tout bas et
tout le monde finit par leur savoie où
il y en a c'est ce que ico il cancel et
auprès de leur compagnie créative mais
est-ce que vous citez au québec mais
tout est une jeune compagnie canadienne
mais un mec qui chante internati
accompagner les jets je le cite cgpi je
connais d'autres qui ont travaillé avec
les gc jusqu'à moi mettons ce ça me rend
inconfortable de devoir justifier le
shipping time amis c'est un nom qui
maîtrisent ils font confiance le décor
mais que la réponse
qui fait les lois mais autrement dit
quand je leur ai écrit monde y donne
cette adresse là puisque genre pas
l'adresse servi sa clientèle sur le site
web de ce genre l'adresse de quelqu'un
en particulier si la suite à des
problèmes dit leur décrire le camp sosa
marchal il y avait une ligne directe
clame alors logistique était pas
optimale quel site ferme genre est le
surlendemain qu'on fasse notre richard
mon dieu qu'est ce qui se passe puis
j'en avais parlé aux gars qui fait mon
site qui est en france brad mais il me
dit baisse parce que le nom de domaine
d'un incident de ce genre la dernière
chose que tu veux changer est-ce que les
steaks entendu les tirs et la banque et
la vend pas comme ça que justice était
comme tellement tellement loge puis
jeudi avec mon abonnés on a vraiment
mené une petite enquête j'ai montré sur
mon agent ce qui
s'est vraiment dit il
j'ai jamais été payé pour ce contrôleur
mais je m'y attendais aussi on sait même
pas essayé d où ces personnes n'étaient
pas c'est pas une entreprise ait pas de
québécois non non non on n'y était pas
ici ça m'a parlé de ça parce que j'ai
demandé qu'on traverse la plus grave
contraire c'est ça ouais que ça fait
jaser le monde pendant un jour j'ai eu
comme 2d aime un peu négatif déjà
possesseur baissé à cause d'affaires
quand même qu'on peut plus vous trop ce
que les influenceurs psy je leur ai
vraiment expliqué que c'était une
arnaque
moi je me suis fait en éclats se sauter
sachant que c'est du rap shipping de
tout ce contexte toutes les mensonges
qui ont fait ça n'avait pas de bon sens
parce que je n'ai pas les détails mais
je t'ai comme je l'aurais jamais fait le
dit mais non la plupart m'ont écrit
juste des messages de soutien déjà
envoyé on le connaissait depuis on sait
que tu ferais pas ce fait rassuré mais
sur le coup le où j'ai trouvé ça
mais on s'entend c'est là que ça remet
en perspective mans des controverses
dans les pas eu beaucoup le team et
comme pays tue de plus grande intensité
le sauf que ça remet en perspective mais
tout le monde sait ça leur arrive une
instit vraie grosse affaire qui peuplent
le plaisir est partout du velours
disparaître pendant tout ce qui rend
vraiment des médias j'ai l'impression le
titre c'était des controverses internes
sur instagram si moindrement c'est la
personne inconnue peut-être ça sort
comme dix pages à potins et son facebook
cool mais là moi je pense pas que ça
s'est étendu jusqu'à 90 hectares city
avait fait un article sur moi c'est pas
pour nous bachir le tester juste pour
mettre au courant les gens que strauss
kahn c'est tout
mais c'est quand même bon et pas plus de
dix ans ce genre pas avoir eu de pouvoir
se dit quelque chose qui avait pas de
bon sens il faut avoir fait quelque
chose qui est qui était chez corinne
plus pour une compagnie qui est sympa de
120 peux pas
regretter d'avoir dit oui oui mais non
avec la teinte après un viêt je pense
que c'est ce faut que tu passes tes mots
piqué tout peut se retourner contre toi
fait que j'ai toujours tout à fait
attention quand même au dessus de tout
déjà vu la police vegan des bars qui
n'empêcha pas parce que le maquillage
les cosmétiques c'est quelque chose
quand même qui vient chercher beaucoup
vegan fait que je ne porte pas de
jugement par action mais les autres ça
peut être quelque chose qu'il était
encore pas mal de petits jobs mais
jamais de manière
intense et plus ils vont me demander
peux tu mets ton parler dans une
prochaine vidéo de produits bureautiques
week end c'est plus eux mais au début je
pense tu parles de l'alimentation mais
non non non ça devait arriver et ben non
justement vu que je n'ai
jamais fait vraiment de gros coming out
parce que je mange de grossesse ivg et
vegan fait chantre les deux jouer et pas
de terme pour ça yao flexitariens oui je
sais ce que je disais mettons pas les
jdidis mais je sais pas je dis je mange
végétarien maintenant à la maison puis
des choses comme ça parce que c'est
quand même nouveau que tu mon bain
nouveau c'est venu en deuxième que tu
montres ta vie à toi le tuer au delà du
maquillage non le tuer parce que tu as
commencé vraiment au début leur ton nom
le haut des buteurs clip de commencer
vraiment maquillage ça c'est en quelle
année
je vais tenir mon cours de maquillage
ces sujets dont je vais essayer youtube
puis avec moi le but c'était comme un
peu pour me faire connaître comme
maquilleuse parce que ce soit en cours
dans le but de adnane
georges savais pas que youtube c'est une
option et qu'on pouvait en vie mais ce
n'était que mon pauvre non mais ça
commençait à commencer en anglais
m'attend si je fais quand même que les
vacances étaient vraiment est une ode
jdd youtube youtube heures avec
québécois natif de diakhaté parce c'est
maintenant il ya déjà un modèle pied des
jeux comme jordi monkeys montauban se
disant genre est l'état de la grotte
d'avoir une chaîne youtube puis georges
je veux être connus dans l'ana mais tant
que tu lui fais maintenant que tu fasses
l'époque les autres aucune idée où ça va
mener non mais non c'est ce que je
prenais je prenais vraiment une chance
de me faire découvrir via ce finalement
ça n'a pas marché au sens que je suis
pas un producteur de cinéma il va pas
garder sur youtube pour une maquilleuse
c'est pas là mais ça me fait quand
nikeplus com et en rosé chronicles
beauté mais cap sur le botté que j'ai
fait pour ma chaîne pour d'autres
chaînes aussi à travers les années au
début mais non c'était vraiment dans
cette optique là un petit peu au début
c'était pas si sûr d'être connue ce
n'est pas de faire de l'argent mon dieu
je savais même pas qu'on peut parler
sous le adsense et commencer je
comprenne un riad sonne ça commence et
puis encore moins les partenaires les
plus création spéciale non ça a été long
avant ma première puis dans le temps
j'avais aucune idée non plus de ma
valeur c'est quoi le terrain
mais sans gâcher mon jeu de
hockey j'avais pas de références loti et
s'arrêter à l'international je te pas en
contact avec ces grandes youtube est
anglophone attend l'été mais mais mais
mais première vidéo qu'on m'a demandé
pour cesser de shenzhen mais premier
contre eux j'irai pas la marque même si
sûrement qu'elle existe plus le mais je
pense que pays 25 pièces la capsule ça
peut commencer avec pias ça n'importe
quoi mais je tenais mousser en tant que
maquilleuse je savais pas combien charge
déjà mais j'aime l'argent c'est ça la
force si c'est là que l'agencement
tanning de cons parce que mettre une
valeur sur sa personne sur ce qu'on fait
c'est tellement tough le oui après sa
délégation en son propre nom
je penserai pas game de charger les prix
que mon âge en charge en jeu pendant un
jeu beau - wall c'est ça le chic et
beaucoup d'eau soit dans l' agence ou
d'opter créateurs de contenu qui pensent
la même chose mais aussi soul on est
quand même ça vous aussi ok
c'est sûr mais après ça se passe comme
étant quelqu'un que tu travailles en
public qui sait que 20 mettons les bois
de télécharge pour des peu vite dit
chris même à ce prix là c'est un aubaine
oui c'est fou quand même la star ac 6
après des années avant de chercher coûte
combien mettons une pub dans le métro
quelque chose
non c'est normal de charges ont marqué
moi ce que je fais de la pub gratos la
saison je parle plus souvent maintenant
de produits de manière non sponsorisés
je pense que les gens me tape poséidon
et non plus ils savent ça fait partie
je pense pour rire sur mac 80% de tout
ce que je fais mais ton sur instagram c
était oui j'ai reçu les produits mais
j'ai quand je reçois les produits et pas
de contrôler les gens partis cheveux si
gm qui est je peux tout ce que je veux
tu le
7e marché rapidement chaîne youtube ça a
été comme l'on est graduelle et commence
a été graduelle cette idée fois yannick
dans le temps qu'il y avait des mentions
de le plus gros youtuber de sa levée
mais moi j'ai eu peur sur le fait que ça
a été plus de travail acharné et
continue ouais grave mais sèchement
doucement
ça a pris des années mais quoi le rythme
des danses des cotons rites de vidéos le
discrédit sur tf1 par semaine je pense
j'ai tout à fait un par semaine mais
c'est ça c'est le fait qui est en fait
pendant vraiment des années que tu te
fais je pensais ta place éventuellement
par youtube a vraiment changé aussi le
depuis dix ans mais ça a été vraiment
progressif et pendant tout ce temps
l'autre tu travailles
professionnellement comme maquilleuse ou
ssh que j'attendais je faisais déjà
essayé en fait mon bus en faisant mon
cours de maquillage au collège lasalle
c'était de devenir une maquilleuse
professionnelle puis de vivre de mai
contre mais à l'école nous avait bien
dit que ça pourrait prendre jusqu'à sept
ans pour une maquilleuse à montréal
parce qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup ça pas
moi jusqu'à sept ans pour en vivre de
ses contrefacteurs jeter comme préparer
à ce que ça soit y est
c'est fait ça juste a donné que j'
partie ma chaîne youtube en même temps
un peu plus tard est venu mon blog aussi
été fait que j'ai comme diversifié un
petit dans les premières années je me
rappellerai juste en 2013 même année
j'avais comme steve jobs simultanément
mais tout dans la beauté mais mettons et
j'avais fait mais ton de la vente
poursuit au make-up le comme quand ils
représentent en tout venant et pharmacie
et c'est d'avoir déjà un maquis
blessantes et vend des produits aussi
j'avais ce j'ai enseigné au collège
durocher celle du rocher voyons oui
durocher saint-lambert il ya une
activité de maquillage artistique le
fait que je faisais ça pour les
cerfs-volants 4,5 ja l'enseigné le sait
bien payé mais c'était loin de chez nous
le fait qu éventuellement ça allait
marquer si j'avais ma chaîne youtube je
faisais des vidéos pour d'autres chaînes
et j'étais comme chroniqueuse pour
emerson en france mais des petites
chroniques bottines 50 euros fois par
semaine enfin que j'avais comme cette
job en tout
mais j'ai commencé à travailler wirth le
séparant les amis étaient encore dans le
fond au cégep mois se passe qu'est aux
seconds agissent hugues light
maquilleuse faut que j'aille voir
comment tout ça c'est un flash pauvres
ça me fera pas qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
parce que mon attention
ça arrive c'est ce point qui n'est pas
quelque chose qui ne peut même pas sûr
que les gars
je me suis jamais mis le maquillage
l'occupation
non mais c'est ça puisqu'elle ne s'est
pas de maquilleuses il ya comme riez qui
m'a emmené par se jettent tout en lui
quand j'étais jeune mais ton est plein
d'intérêt avec tout ce qui est
artistique j'aimais ce qui était plus là
dedans mais tant que j'ai deux genres
des marques
maquillage je les ai pas trop vu venir
le coup j'ai eu un intérêt pour ce
commence à me pratiquer un peu sur mes
amis à café le genre au secondaire puis
à mener c'est qu'on est et je me
rappelle georges et une image en tête
que l'on était dans le cours d'éducation
choix de carrière puis il fallait faire
un choix dit il nous faut faire les
petits seul comme ton profil l'auto
entrepreneur social des choses comme ça
moi je pense et artistique social de
coin de meuble puis il m'a dit j'ai
vraiment je suis un flash dans ma tête
et comme akiyoshi combien oui je
commence à aimer c'est pourquoi je
crains pas maquilleuse j'ai fait bah je
vais m'informer sur le sujet si j'avais
fait élèves d'un jour au collège lasalle
puis de sopi mais c'est vraiment parti
d'un flash dans ma tête le pij et comme
jamais changé d'idée après cfoot était
certaine ben ouais ouais avant ce que je
voulais faire autre chose c'était comme
si jamais tout ce qui est artistique et
je lègue comédienne pendant un bon bout
de temps parce que secondaire est en
fait j'aime et autant leur plastique que
leur dramatique que utiliser finalement
c'est un peu plus stiller plastique le
passé pour moi le maquillage quand même
on veut dire une forme dans le silo
veulent pas que c'est juste aller dans
cette voie le g pour changer d'idée ce
fait que j'ai pas fait cégeps d'aller
directement faire mon cours de
maquillage professionnel à la salle
parce que c'est ce que je voulais je ne
voyais plus de gens du plateau télévisé
en outre que si tous les enfants ce qui
est quelque chose qui m'attire et en
particulier au début bonne question
j'avais compris en tout cas en faisant
le court que ça ouvre bien des portes le
passé des maquilleuses y en a dans
plusieurs milieux justement le plus
vendu chez l'abbé le maquis pour des
films la télé les shoots des défilés de
mode voyager avec ce il y avait pris
l'option justement dans le temps il n'y
avait pas proposé à youtube et options
maintenant je sais qu'ils font
pour beaucoup de gens et directement de
sa chance aussi via les médias sociaux
là contrairement à moi ce matin jeux
avec michael en télé on m'avait dit il
c'est mieux que tous connaissent
quelqu'un mais jamais donc moi qui
travaillais à radio canada mais c'est
comme ça va être long outils même cinéma
faut que tu as besoin d'avoir des
crédits pour comme monter dans la liste
puis tout là où lui dire des choses
comme cela a déjà commencé à proposer
tout à fait ce que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai testé un peu de tout les premières
années comme maquilleuse de thé je
faisais autant et le week end des
maquillages jeter sur des enfants pour
des festivals des choses une seule je
faisais sur serein sur un bateau le
maquillage artistique
après je maquille un shoot créatif avec
photographes mannequins qu'on aimait
bien c'est ça j'ai touché un peu à tout
sauf vraiment télé parce que comme si il
faut que tu entres la date et l'heure
est bien longtemps parent aimant mais je
me suis jamais rendu en fait à essayer
de vivre de justes mais contre eux parce
que il vous trouve est arrivé dans ma
vie un peu en même temps sa sas il ya eu
comme un point de croisement et que j'ai
dû faire un choix aussi le thé c'est ce
qui tendrait qu'est ce que ça donne être
le les tests au secondaire
souviens pas non ce n'est pas que ça
donne et je sais que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de monde que ça donnait genre
agriculteurs des prêts c'est que
genre allez dans l'armee moi c'est
aller dans l'armée ah ouais voilà
patrice tribunal a
officié
[Rires]
à quel point c'était pas
qui ça peut pas de sens quand arrive en
4e année du secondaire c'est tout et
échangistes et un déclic de pareils ça
c'est le chemin mais quand tu arrives en
quatrième année de secondaire l'année
d'après faut que tu prennes un choix
dicté pour le résultat jean
legault qui tels des cosmonautes que moi
j'ai l'impression que c'était si vous
les temps et l'une à quelque chose
foutez moi que l'étudiant musique mais
je
t'ai pas
évidemment l'accueil c'est justement il
y en a tellement à montréal en tout cas
la compétition est forte depuis jeudi à
montréal mais passe aussi dans d'autres
villes ont moins besoin c'est sur la
télé ou dit ce témoin partout avec moi
aussi mais en même temps mais montre que
mes parents mes proches m'ont toujours
encouragé le fait que mercy est d'avoir
toujours cru en moi même erreur car ça
fait le chemin plus youtu be on peut et
on peut lever les 1000 adultes et au
tableau ne serait plus parce que s'il
n'y avait pas deux ça pouvait exister le
titre
je me souviens que j'avais genre
99% artistique
peut plus appeler
les cubains qui s'appelait non quand
même c'est pas quelque chose qui guide
ces sondes en famille de ma vie parce
que peu importe on parlait aussi mais je
me rappelle puis comme tu dis
les réponses il ya personne qui s'était
genre grandes chances qu'ils t'ont règle
non
le test
il ya beaucoup de sorties d'un débouché
de débouchés dans l'europe n'a jamais
été genre suis ta passion le sait jamais
ça la réponse est non
on l'a dit est déjà à quai ou québec
mettons des besoins de plus
d'agriculteurs à qui on dit on veut dire
qu'ils demandaient nos aspirations il y
avait bien légaux qui avait dit jean moi
je vous fais l'argent beaucoup y était
juste un acteur fait peu importe la job
bible aller dans quelque chose de
payante moi perso ce n'est pas dans mes
carthage étaient plus tard ce que je
fais il devrait être le faire une
aspiration car
ces caisses qui était quand même réalisé
que youtube son ami si cela était quoi
le ya toujours une vidéo en étape est le
fait qu'un mot charles et vient de se
passer quelque chose puis que je
pourrait pousser là dedans davantage le
temps mais je me rappelle m'être ma
vidéo la plus vue encore à ce jour qui
est très bien mais je pense qu'à date
d'être 2012 le fait que je n'ai pas ces
machines c'est les 12 erreurs de
maquillage que j'avais fait la moitié du
visage corps et équipier ben avait en
même temps c'est subjectif moitié en
étant ce que tu disais est une erreur
très exagéré le fond de teint vraiment
pas de la bonne couleur des sources
ebooks creuser la voiture
[Musique]
a vraiment vraiment pas gagné beaucoup
gens qui ont repris le concept puisque
c'est le schéma prévu le jeu pourri pour
me rappeler des chiffres mais c'est dans
les millions de vues
mais non 3
oui ça c'est plus proche de 4 mais il
n'y a pas eu de je pense d'un moment
fort c'est moi tout était vraiment
graduelle des minimes avec ce genre j'ai
coché adsense évidemment les premiers
mois j'avais passé la bri plus les mêmes
règles aujourd'hui non plus mais était
une fois que j'avais je pense tu es tu
mets le pièces pour pour avoir un
paiement après ou saint pierre je ne
sais pas je pense que quand atteignait
mille piastres les gloses un peu
une fois que j'ai eu l'impression
j'avais tout a eu axa a été graduelle
mais même à ce jour dit je reçois des
fois les mêmes montants que il ya trois
ans cette salle est pas les vues et les
bus ou les contrôles
puis
métier mais tant qu'ils anticipent une
vidéo d'eux mêmes qui peuplent c'est sûr
que sans cette semaine le jardin une
jarre d'effervescence puisqu'il ya plein
de nouveaux mondes qui se joignent plus
tu dois faire comme acquis non l'oeil
comme si ça allait me donner un bon
petit boss le oui c'est clair si cette
façon moi j'ai fait ce progressivement
aussi les switchs de était de pouvoir
juste vivre mettons deux machines est ce
que j'avais mis cette route jobs fait
que j'ai relâché comme je
l'étais à l'époque quand j'ai commencé
j'ai habité
qu'est ce que j'avais à payer à part mon
cell maintenant pas grand chose mais non
ça c'est bien fait après ce que pourrait
pour la suite des choses physiques et
youtube changé dans le fond c'est quoi
la différence là avec méthode de youtube
le 10 ans versus aujourd'hui dans ce
sous sas en vue puis la vidéo youtube en
mettant l'intérêt de plus en plus du
rôle de simple demande qu'on ce oui
c'est ça oui définitivement ya plus de
compétition mais je récuse est ce que
vous vous à regarder des vidéos il ya
dix ans sur youtube
c'est ça les regarde je pense que je
regardais moubarak avait peut-être donné
ce genre
est-ce que vous aviez conscience qu'avec
des créateurs des jeux au québec le
petit chat
parce que je faisais ça dans le fond
c'est valable qui se débat la majorité
font puce est aujourd'hui l'artiste l
époque si gabbro à people j'ai commencé
dans ces halls pillay en a un petit peu
encore qui en font aujourd'hui mais
[ __ ] que mais pour différentes raisons
non seulement passer ça c'est dur
d'assurer sa pérennité et puis on dit
définitivement plus de compétitions que
quand j'ai commencé
elisor c'est vraiment toi exane avait
commencé avant moi déjà connaissance
moment lui mais elle avait commencé
avant - ouais ouais je peux à peine un
mois c'est un monde que le 4 5 1 je
connaissais pas je connaissais puis le
podcast quand même temps la sorte qu'on
a rencontré beaucoup de demandes du web
montrent que ça mais j'en ressentais pas
quelque chose que j'avais à exister mais
je connaissais pas ça parce que c'était
la maison que maintenant c'est comme
vraiment plus ancré dans nos villes sont
connus pitié mettons les jeunes
aujourd'hui
lily en consomme je pense beaucoup et
encore ça mais je pense en plus aux
petits clubs
je pense c'est que c'est plus c'est
addictif je sais pas si vous y allez des
fois ce type d'objets non mais j'ai
jamais pour l'expert expérimenté pied
c'est au début tu comprends pas trop le
je pense qu'on a pas prise mais mange le
fait que je me sentais déjà un peu trop
vieille comme tout mais au tamis l'once
de comac et c'est sun and happy tunes à
tout le monde tombe à crolles dans les
semaines à venir il a failli perdre la
notion du temps là dessus comme pas
possible le style est en défaut le monde
je pense y voit une vidéo youtube d'une
demi-heure sens commun avec le wii wheel
écoute en faisant autre chose puis tout
ça mais en même temps cette chronique
par l'agent deux heures puis patrons
comme ça c'est plus ce que c'était
dans les films j'en ai un mais j'ai
décidé il ya pas si longtemps que ça me
tentait pas continuer puisque je suis
trop de choses à faire partout il ya
trop de choses il y en a qui font que tu
dis s'ils vont devenir tik tok famille
cela mais ils font que sutil font pas
nécessairement une chaîne youtube si
j'essaye de faire une vidéo par semaine
son machin principal puis une somme h12
vlog lafaro si entre-temps qui tarde
bitumeux convaincu que l'os est toxique
et instagram ont repris concept livres
inédits comme j'avais déjà ma communauté
le puits qui est étiqueté beaucoup
montré à des inconnus fac c'est le fun
pour te faire découvrir mais en même
temps souvent des gens très jeunes sur
twitter pas se mentir la tige en bois
dans les commentaires c'est des fois des
enfants le n'hésitez pas non plus
nécessairement des gens qui allaient
transférer sur ma chaîne youtube c'est
sûr je n'ai pas aidé mettons le la
business dans le fond on voit maintenant
mais c'est maintenant si tu vends
quelque chose puis vendre quelque chose
ça s'appelle we vendre un produit mais
si ça peut être aussi vente apte à
personne un [ __ ] tribune puis devant
quelque chose toc toc c'est peut-être
pas la meilleure place pour le
déplacement de produits sur tictoc j'ai
eu comme - 2h02 contre eux que j'ai fait
métier je suppose parce que parce que je
préfère puis si ce n'est pas deux
rémunérations entrepôts québec pour
l'instant pour les créateurs factuel et
les gens qui en sortent à chaque jour ça
leur demande du temps mais titi on
excite inquiète j'ai mieux mettre sept
ans le sur youtube que je m'en fous tu
pas avoir de placement de produit mais
mes vidéos vont être
monétisée si tu penses pas régulièrement
mais un peu comme une toupie toul mais
c'est une ligue en existe faut que je
pense à chaque jour moi j'en faisais pas
chaque jour puis emmené j'ai tellement
fait des longues pauses que ça marchait
pu le lire il instagram marché mieux ça
que j'ai dit mais qu'elles vont
continuer leur lutte et j'aimerais sont
aussi que tous les types de vidéos de
contenu qui marchent pieds comme comme
tu dis beaucoup d'enfants là dessus il
faut que tu fasses du contenu as a si
spécifique est assez de cépie deux fois
puis le jeu peut porter de jugement
métier on dit que je vois des méthodes
et tik tok pas moi je veux pas de
spectacle mais des fois mettons il les
reportages sur instagram pigeât oui il
faut c'est comme
si week-end 30 ans qui fait ce genre je
pourrai manger ce que je veux je
convoque tête en train de marcher sur
des oeufs brusquer personne sauf que
jamais tant que steve je poste avec
quinze ans je fais ok c'est cute mais le
genre à gragnague lawn à d'autres fins
ce conte une ogive genre de danse
oui je comprends le nom c'est vrai que
c'est plus ces jeunes qui vont faire se
détend c'est tout puis ceux qui payent
le plus c'est qu'ils me viennent en tête
justement la plus connue charli
d'améliorer je sais pas lesquels l'armée
à l'automne promettant où elle vraiment
plus jeune que moi qu'est 29 moutons
fait que non c'est ça je me suis mort il
ya trente deux ans qu'ils essaient de
répliquer c'est
tout comme huntsman faut vraiment que tu
utilises les sons dans le moment qu'ils
sont populaires où le challenge qui est
populaire puis les maquillages avait
souvent des trucs ultra extravagant
genre de gros mais qu'au petit edwin de
transformation mais ce n'est pas simple
dans six films où j'avais tellement de
misère n est pas juste comme jouer avec
leurs api de montage je trouve qu'un sa
gamme du rire sont beaucoup plus simples
à comprendre plus intuitif
comme juste s'habituer d'enfants avec ma
caméra dans l'autre sens un horizontal
fait que je me suis tanné le plein
d'enfants dont ce même la communauté des
fois pas nécessairement envers moi mais
quand que tu en fait j'aime mieux su
sauvegarder des tic toc que d'en faire
mais quand je regardais des fois que je
lisais les commentaires
facebook the social media embellie
s'explique j'ai spontanément
mais on les mettait son tik tok ou si
gentil mettant sur instagram les
commentaires souvent le monde réagisse
et elton john et la répugnance jury vous
déjà des fois c'est fait tout le temps
genre s'il y avait un débat c'est tout
le temps de quoi qu'ils élevaient la
pince et qui quand même un préfet dans
la dans la malle respect puis dans le
cas mais les gars j'aime à ce que vous
faites mais d'été la force plusieurs
suspects est que ces
genres bise à son accent
fait de commentaire de montre aucune
idée on est qui on tombe et là tu
comprennes poser quoi demande des
quadras mort oui euh c'est gros plus ça
me fait réaliser que c'était jean sait
comment parler que j'avais au début du
double non moins mais justement parce
que des vidéos tout et tout le monde est
comme un peu inconnu les y avait pas
encore des grosses stars de youtube au
sens où le petit une française veut sa
revanche lui qui piquait j'ai un accent
québécois maintenant mon but était tout
le temps ce pigment aux usa mais c'est
toujours des commentaires sur mon accent
pi2 où je viens ici tous fils ouais
ouais parce que ces sédiments qui
cherchent du vidéo francophone contact
avec les français au plus tôt pourquoi
les pistes est une des raisons pourquoi
je me suis lancé aussi c'est que il y
avait un billet valait qu'alexandra
larouche qui faisait avant moi des jeux
sur youtube dans la beauté lifestyle
rendu plus lifetime moutons mais quand
je tapais cse mettons tutorial tout rien
le maquillage yeux bleus je tombais tout
le temps juste sur quelques françaises
qui venaient se lance et puis sinon le
reste toutes anglophones suffit que je
vais faire du coin comme au québec pour
les québécoises mais dans le fond et
dans le fond quelle erreur parce que
youtube d'international facture allait
toucher toute la francophonie dans mes
temps c'est quoi ton ton public mettons
pourcentage tri du québec mais c'est
beaucoup plus en france le drôle ça tout
temps été vraiment plus en france et
souvent avec du recul je me rends compte
d'amoureux côtoyer d'autres bars on s'en
parle de six haut-parleurs puis tout le
monde que des centaines de milliers
d'abonnés au québec c'est parce qu'ils
ont beaucoup d'abonnés en france acteur
disposition tellement plus sotelma puis
si ça on va chercher plus la rda parti y
mettons nos jours notre truc on saute du
monde québécois fait que gentil mouton
daniel bélanger en france qui le
reçoivent tout le monde va sans alcool
c'est qu'on parle de sujets d'actualité
vraiment québécois on parle actis un
québécois quand il fait quelque chose
qui est maquillage le verset chercher
tant qu'on le cherche la francophonie
n'a répondu tant qu'homme comprend une
tour 105 non mais je ne sais pas ce
qu'il y en ait qui les français
comprennent pas
constant 4,7 vidéo est ce que tu penses
de parler un français genre après
internationale non si je fais pas exprès
de sortir des grosses expressions
québécoises mais je vais parler comme je
parle le pied advienne que pourra même
être fière je lisais mais comment tu as
mon dernier blogue pjak et comédien
j'aime beaucoup des vidéos mais j'étais
propre
et youtube à québécois que jean rayon
caisse malaxant
avantage pour être encore plus large si
moi j'irais pas manqué comme un français
sur deux qui adore l'accent québécois
puis l'autre qui de l'impôt je suis mes
impressions en ayant voyagé la bofi
toutes les commandes reçues
elles sont deux
dans l'axé on a cassé la main
ou djaout souvient qu'ils reconnaissent
pas l'accent parce qu'ils ont peut-être
jamais entendu mais c'est parce que la
droite allait en france on m'avait dit
mais c'est parce que pauvre il n'y a pas
de tant de québécois qui viennent
visiter puis comment non parce que moi
tu mets ton l'europe ça tout a été comme
a dream destination de cuba
j'aurai mon argent depuis que j'étais
jeune pour aller en angleterre qui était
comment on voyage de réactifs et que je
savais pas ce qu'il y at il beaucoup
plus de français qui viennent de
nouveaux quais des québécois parce que
nous les québécois ils partent plus dans
le sud n'ont fait que je savais pas si
on me l'expliquer la boxe et si on me
disait tu passes ton accent newson
exotiques limite là parce qu'il y en a
pas beaucoup faki et même l'autre fait
si on avait pris un taxi avec city avec
qui j'étais en train autres youtube
québécois aussi le gars nous demande
mais tronçon est de l'espagne où des
gardes n'importe où fakihani quand j'ai
jamais entendu ces sorties ici on est
beaucoup plus exposés on le connaît
depuis qu'on est des doublages français
des démissions de
même limité
de natation il y en avait des principes
des foyers séduite elle accentue nous à
linverse on est capable d'être correct
le clemi aux autres sont incapables
je pensais comme gad elmaleh de mémoire
le qu'ils étaient capables mais à part
ça je sais pas non mais l'inversé grippe
c'est à cause d'eux comment qu'on parle
la hauteur il ya de quoi qui était qu'on
m'avait expliqué qu' on parle plus beau
je pense aux berges pour l'exprimer
vraiment le maire dit que comme quoi
qu'on a plus de facilité à la poignée
des actions maintenant
vous seul le luron qui sont capables de
vraiment modifier leur accent mais genre
vraiment vraiment moi je pense à
l'acteur qui jouait dr house le fait que
hugh laurie qui s'appelle lui y est un
anglais qu'un qui parle jours dans un
camp qui ghettoïse me plaît reçoit jean
meilleur acteur dans une série de
comédie de l'est il parle avec un accent
anglais est tellement deep le genre de
son axe naturel dans l'émission il jauge
à un américain puis il est temps il
parle avec un accent américain tout le
temps les pcistes lui ça paraît jamais
c'est fou le jouet qu'on actionne
m'imagine c'est comme ça plane étudiants
français comme seul ça se fait je pense
que oui mais ça
j'avais fait à manier avec une coupe de
cours de diction et qui ne peuvent pas
parce que j'étais le genre j'étais
impôts de 15 milliards ils ont parlé
mais elle sait vraiment ce qui s'était
vraiment comme
d'apprendre les sonorités et eli lilly
les uns les anti-jo pour avoir un
français mettons-le or massif le temps
puis c'est que la manière que tu places
et sont que tu places dont la rencontre
de ce type i mais c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un entraînement comprendre puis
de le répéter pour que ça devienne ses
habitudes ses fumées
alors que maman de la sortie avec
rwe bâclé
l'imitateur le québécois qui était à las
vegas ah ouais
lorsque le l'on ne reviendra pas être
mais apparemment quelqu'un la plaie chez
eux ce n'est jamais la même personne
peut prendre le temps quelqu'un d'autre
qui répondait jean lui depuis qu'il est
tout petit genre qui était tout petit
billet mi temps quelqu'un pleut il
parlait comme cette personne en
mettant les
machines absolutisme et on sait si chuck
comme céline d'une bonne chance si je
sentais comme un gentil comme adèle à ce
niveau là c'est comme
si un sur dix mille mais elle allait à
l'effet tout
croyable il ya une vidéo
que je regarde j'aurais quand même
régulièrement piqué que je pleure à
chaque fois c'est véronique à
[Rires]
chaque fois elle sera un show en france
d'après genre de menly d'artistes sera
celle des surstocks chiotti qui a fini
son numéro avec
retour d'edith piaf la pige à sa porte
puis c'est comme l'éclair a change pas
sa façon
elle devient dit pierre la chante
l'hymne à l'amour puis le caecum de jean
pagé des fictions grasset insight elle
fait le genre de tout le monde sur le
plateau de laverie blood gâteau
à chaque fois je mangeais des jeux
violents tard samedi incroyable
incroyable aux médecins mais tout cela
regarde pas ramer
et des vidéos je regarde cela
de voir
ce dont je la regarde bon bien
j'ai vu la vidéo
makheia un
cv une
compétence apprend à faire ce maquillage
de transphobie l'osm et on enfile mais
c'est un grand plus longue je fais juste
comme le faire pour une photo mais c'est
surtout au moins trois heures mais la
danse et ce dans le cadre d'une vidéo
youtube dans lwin je me gardais plus que
ce parce que le temps que le temps que
je m'arrête pas le faire le maquillage
puis après ça c'est que je me fait
autant une intro pour mes vidéos de
winfakt faut que j'aille soit le green
screen où étaient mes accessoires un
beau décor de près fac plus ce film et
c'est sur les petites répliques ou un
habit ses imitations des bons
mais je me garde plus que quatre heures
le profil mais il faut pas que j'avais
quelque chose à présenter quatre et six
heures de film mais s'il est ce parce
que c'est ma classe comme ceux ci c'est
débile mais c'est simplement
impressionnant
j'en fais pas assez souvent justement
c'est long qu'il faut le prévoir puis
souvent logés test avant aussi parce que
la fin avec les maquillages de
transformation c'est que tant que je les
professions moi je sais pas vraiment et
je peux me doutais que telle personne
vaut futé surface mais tant que les
peaux fait jaser pas aux tirs j'aime
mieux arriver genre préparé dans ma
vidéo youtube ci je sais où je m'en vais
puiser ta pâte lors du math ont fait que
j'ai les maquillages dans luigi's et
c'est une fois avant c'est quoi le
processus mettant leurs gardes
mettons-la la phase 2 alan rickman
dallas et ce sont nos
athlètes se prend en photo plus te dit
tout est dit que tu vois mettons
j'imagine que tu es capable de voir
maintenant les répits qu'est-ce que ça
prendrait pour faire simple c'est que ce
qui se passe mais tant qu'ils pointent
du oasis et ça commence par une
recherche de photos des comme au kiki je
vais face parce que dans ma série dans
louis jean série harry potter et chaque
année je me dis bon qui je fait je
pensais route avant c'était genre
voldemort que je me demandais qui
fâchent avait estimé que donne à gordes
mettons mais c'était trop dur ça va
vraiment trop dur autre que moi je
trouvais que je ressemblais pas ses
factures je vais essayer jusqu'à temps
que je trouve un qui s appelle lui-même
re de la première fois j'ai laissé ça
moi je suis comme pas sûr je m'entraîne
chermiti comme non non je pense tous
ressenti je l'avais mis dans mystery
close fin août puis le kg là pour du
monde convoqué parce que des fois j'ai
de la misère à moto évalué après
justement à 4 heures que je concentré
dans moi parce que je vois juste août
zafour tafer papier toute petite voix
plus été capable voilà
tout mais bref je suis je me disais
sûrement que rogue ça marcherait pas
parce qu'il est vraiment une face quand
même particulière le tir sans peur à
personne de bâton puis c'est des fois
c'est ça c'est que maintenant on a un
nez qui est vraiment différente waben
certains mois ses maquillages russe et
que je mets pas de protéger ce pack tout
est fait avec des ombres et des lumières
fac il faut que tu ils mettront un et
courbes et un nez aquilin et retroussé
c'est vraiment quand même difficile il
ya des limitations dans le dos des
battants mais cette série là c'est comme
ça que je la fais fait que je vais faire
le plus proche possible en maquillage de
tes ordres qu'on appelle le message
analyse la face longtemps je vais
chercher des vraiment des bons close up
hd de la personne je regarde plein de
photos pour essayer de voir ses
commettants j'avais la personne devant
moi ça serait quoi sa structure ses
traits faciaux qu'après ce sujet c'est
que peut prendre plein de photos en même
temps parce que ça peut rendre sur un
peu confus le fait que je me prends une
ou deux photos que je trouve que la
personne sort semble particulièrement et
puis je vais suivre ça dans le fond fac
la première étape a précisé de mettre ma
face notre genre le plus possible parce
que sinon tu es très influent ce genre
ceux de la personne qui est en cours
afin qu'il faut que je fasse comme un
canevas blanc le comme si tu parles
femmes scratch sur une page blanche taxi
se cache t sz ur site mais un fond de
teint opaque et oui tout est effacé le
plus possible du visage puis par dessus
c'est comme tu veux dessiner ou peindre
les traits de la personne c'est un peu
solide et c'est fou je savais qu dénonce
à juste désormais linate
peut changer
on sait seul changer la forme de ton
visage que c'est vraiment comme du
dessin de maquillage de théâtre c'est
comme du dessin
c'est vraiment le même principe le même
commenter le contenu ring vous avez
peut-être déjà entendu parler de ça mais
ça c'est un maquillage beauté mais c'est
la même chose on prend des ombres des
lumières mettant une poudre bronzante
tam et nantes ont crû de joubert tu as
joué à barvaux la plus fine que cette
illusion d'optique dans le fond c'est
que ce mais c'est quand tu vois des
maquillages encore plus réussie ben
justement comme mettons au bye bye par
exemple ils vont utiliser des prothèses
parce qu'il faut aussi le maquillage
soin et vue de tous les côtés là dans ma
vidéo youtube je peux me permettre de
rester de face le temps que le film
oui parce que si je dois mettant la main
sur mon visage comment je faisais avec
des ombres et des lumières mais il
s'efface mettons pour une photo ou une
vidéo ça passe le mais il va falloir je
me mette vraiment comme du foncé ou la
couleur de mon fond sur le tour de mon
visage et puis ça me fait quand même si
chewing un peu comme ça
m a fait le grand machin cabaye sow doit
être comme un enfant dans un ben oui
c'est son j'aime ce bye bye bye points
mais c'était avant les transfos
6,5 croyable quant à quel point deux
fois avec maquillage qui prétend y
ressemble c'est pas moi c'est pas ma
spécialité les prothèses la gelée a pris
dans mon cours de maquillage mais vu que
j'ai jamais travaillé en cinéma comme
tnt jeu pour l'experte de tout ce qui
est positif prothèse les balles cap
c'est pas ma tasse de thé mais
c'est qu'elle le maquillage
du chapeau est ça peut être
des transformations comme ou des
maquillages juste comme standard
guillemets mais cela que tu dirais même
temps ceux-ci genre mon masque piste
parce que mettons le mais
c'est comme c'est comment n'importe quoi
le faut que tu connaisses pour être
capable de comprendre pourquoi il
quelque chose que tu aimes vraiment on
sait maintenant - maquillage maintenant
je vois je vois plusieurs maquillage
voiture pas de faire un crime c'est
vraiment beau augmenter maquillé mais
jamais capable de textures toile s'est
jamais de la fois qu'une ville
que je réfléchisse quelques j'ai mis
ma série harry potter pourrait vraiment
du fun parce que
c'est sûr que de revivre un peu c'est
très plat chaque année c'est le faut
noter c'est tout des personnages
tellement différent aussi tout le temps
une vo challenge-là vraiment j'ai passé
en noir en particulier c'est ce que met
on vole de morts il y avait été prévu
parce que tu viennes tout le monde
connaît ma demande c'est plus une grosse
transformation qui est un genre moins on
est mis en attente c'était une
cocréation je l'avais fait avec
justement une maquilleuse d'effets
spéciaux si on le fait à 12,2 se
transforme parce qu'ils étaient il ya
pas deux mais en fait moi je t'ai pas
apte à savait pas comment faire des
genres de moulage le pour m'enlever mon
île mais emilie était capable on le fait
à deux
chauffeurs
mais en fait si on le voit dans la vidéo
le mépris bus et si je commence son
studio puis avant faire comment la place
tien faith caste lorsque les conclusions
l'étape métissé vous avez sûrement déjà
officié dans les biens destinés d'un
film ivan de verser un genre de glu
mobile sur les visages
bien vite ils vont comme plâtre et ce
puis c'est surtout les yeux fermés tour
espère juste par les narines c'est
vraiment spécial mathieu comme dépendant
des gens n'aient pas eu mais j'avais des
trous dans les jeux le souviens c'est
appréciable moulton visage
alors quand même que je pressens visuel
ça faisait expliqué marc ecko vraiment
plusieurs étapes avoir rempli qu'à
penser à aller comme et comme je prends
comme un le moule de tafas viala en
béton c'est là dessus mettons à passer
moi je repartais chine où là dessus
avait même écrit une prothèse sur mesure
pour mon éthique fit et son mât face
parce qu'il ya des prothèses dans
l'uriné tu peux acheter dans les
magasins dans louise mais c'est
céder face au réalisme et ont fait
qu'elle m'a fait vraiment de quoi sur
mesure pour je pense le front pique
nique on avait fait fait que c'est sûr
qu'il faut gonfler mettons la partie
autour du nez pour aplatir l'année parce
qu'on peut pour casser mon deux années
là bret carr vient grossir ici se
relever puis refaire les narines plus
haut pour faire comme un certain peu
le même sens reste à g que je sais pas
pourquoi ils l'assument ou
non mais je pense que c'est mort
une partie grâce à peine
ce qui est canadien des
canadiens qui sait tout des gens
incroyables
je sais moi j'ai mon
pc mon gueule défaut genre ces trucs
pierre faucheux lang a plusieurs fois
parce que tu es bateau à se dessine des
yeux mais jarkov suspects c'est plus
c'est vrai les yeux sont où son ex à
bouchain ou psy comme c'est la meilleure
et ses incroyables ces transformations
qu'a fait
vous allez un bon succès aussi avec ça
mais c'est incroyable c est ma préférée
juin pour les maquillages d'illusions
d'optiques c'est pas quelque chose les
foules fait non plus de dents dans cette
envergure là mais un
mais ça pogne beaucoup le maquillage des
illusions d'optique locales et fois que
j'en ai fait ça a vraiment bien marché
pas nécessairement plus baisse a dépassé
celle a fait des trucs d'envergure le
commerce dit le mettons et quand
j'allais à la semaine du 4 julie et
quelques mois je m'étais fait comme
juste un double visage fait que je
reproduisais mes yeux ma bouche times en
effet troublant c'est j'ai sur ma mis
trois heures à le faire un fax est peu
plus long que maquillage de
transformation aussi transformation se
souvient il et costumes labeyrie photo
puis là aujourd'hui mettons le
travail encore comme maquilleuse non non
je le fais pas parce qu'il ya une chose
qui te manque
bonne question justement occupé je
demande à mon train de vie 100% cette
création de contenus sociaux que je
pense pas que je m'en rends compte que
je m'ennuie mais j'aime oui j'aime se
maquiller des gens soit gelée fait
l'aspect ya deux semaines pour ma vidéo
qui va ce samedi qu'on peut dire parce
que le podcast vote après mais dans le
fond c'est un flash que j'ai eu comme
seule autre fois en travaillant à mon
bureau puis j'ai en fait il ya deux
moments qui m'avait écrit que sa fille
s'est mariée le 17 juillet puisqu'elle
me suivait depuis les débuts puisque
c'est grâce à mes titres auxquels elle
est maquillée elle même pour son mariage
permet dire se serait fait que tu y
envoyer un petit mot thé ou un petit
vidéo juste bonne journée de l'europe le
jr flash qui en fait je pourrais
carrément aller la surprendre qui lui
offrirent de la maquiller pour son
mariage avec ses 5 ans l'effectif à que
j'ai dit on la première que je maquille
depuis la pandémie il n'a pas donné que
georges imac et personnes enfin que ça
faisait longtemps que j'ai beaucoup aimé
ça j'aimerais encore se faire ça c'est
sûr mais c'est juste le jeu peut plus
faire les deux
compères étaient vraiment contente a été
surprise c'est un bon maçon un bon
moment on a tout capté sujet sa première
fois j'ai engagé un cameraman ouais
ouais ouais je voulais faire du quad bol
que je pense ça va bien marcher mais ça
va mal fans s'écroule ça
puis maintenant les l'optique réseaux
sociaux parce que ce sont des machines
que c'est une question qui est qui qui
existe parce qu'il n'y a pas encore de
réponse puis deux précédents mais
l'optique de réseaux sociaux comme étant
une carrière sur le long terme c'est
quelque chose qui inquiète parce que
chez nous mettons jeu respiration là
avec une coupe d'autres personnes qui
oeuvrent dans ce milieu là bien mais
c'est quand même mon mail
qu'est ce qui se passe et c'est qui
c'est quoi après quelque chose après ou
est-ce que j'en fais juste continuer
soit parce que tout le monde vieillit en
même temps des publics vis avec nous tu
sais quoi l'est commente entrevoit sud
parce que parce que c'est dans le fond
il n'y a personne qui a fait ça avant
new generation c'est dur de savoir si
lointain je comprends vraiment ta
question puis j'ai pas la réponse que je
me demande c'est vraiment quelqu'un le
dit justement tik tok et sydney fazio
sûrement pas la réponse
mais ça me oui ça m'a longtemps inquiété
peut-être à mi chemin ou dans les
dernières années et dépasse que ceux sur
qui en tant que créatrice vieillissante
sur la plate forme gpon des serments
favorisée par youtube il ya eu des
vraiment des parce que je me suis
inquiété pour mes vues mais l'enfant
c'est que je continue quand même un
pouvoir gagner ma vie avec mes vidéos
puis encore le chemin qui se bat comme
combien de temps encore mais temps mais
lorsque j'étais en gros questionnement
de cesser ce que j'ai vu c'est plus une
question d'ego genre site est encore
capable d'en vivre tu sais quoi qui mach
hitech sud depuis être capable de faire
tout le temps les mêmes vues que
qu'autrefois en
même temps c'est ça tout les créatrices
qui ont commencé en même temps que moi
tout le monde est dans le même bateau le
6e je vais renconter béton il ya des
filles que je suivais - dont tu te
blesses beauté en anglais qui ont comme
encore mettons trop millions d'abonnés à
ce jour mais qui vont faire moins de vue
que moi mais eux la compétition est
encore plus fort que deschamps en beauté
en anglais elle a sa pelouse s'est fait
que je sais pas si c'est combien de
temps quand ça va être possible
d'ailleurs j'avais une vidéo assez
émotive justement castex me disant que
c'était vraiment un peu comme j'étais
encore passionné puis j'aimerais comme
est encore le danger pour 5 10 ans mais
ça va dépendre de voûte et facilement
mais c'est comme this comme un chanteur
simon ne vont plus à ces spectacles qui
achètent puis son cd même si toute la
volonté du monde il pourrait plus
continuer tes ex comme déchire à l'été
mais ce qui est drôle c'est que moi mon
plant based dans le fond mon plan à de
vie parce que mon plan à revisiter avec
maquilleuse s'en rend compte je me
disais je reviendrai à ça mais peut-être
pas non plus tu es un j'ai d'autres
passions aussi puis comme je dis je des
intéressés par tout ce qui est
artistique facquet j'ai tout un peu
suivi plus ce genre tout ce que la vie
me mène depuis selon les opportunités
mais un autre que moi je compte
continuer les médias sociaux jusqu'à
temps que j'en sois et put année puis
que les gens soient les [ __ ] année
noire mais je sais pas en combien de
temps il va falloir se réinventer tout
autant sur d'autres plateformes en même
temps tu sais j'en parlais l'autre avec
une amie youtuber expédie en même temps
et c'est youtube ça ça fait longtemps
que c'est lui justement tenue des ventes
et d'autres applications du double est
restée youtube c'est resté comme
facebook instagram j'ai l'impression que
c'est comme les trous aux principaux qui
vont rester mais mes advienne que pourra
puis lors dramatiques sur quelque chose
qui t'intéresse encore oui oui mon dieu
ça fait vraiment longtemps que j'ai pas
eu d'occasions
l'expérience de jeu maintenant
4 à la dernière fois il ya eu comme une
web série qu'elle jouait mon rôle mais
c'était ce cryptage ce qu'il y avait un
autre pilote aussi que j'ai fait il ya
encore plus longtemps que ce que je t'ai
maquilleuse mais bon c'était script est
aussi c'est avec charles lafortune mais
je pense que le pilote ça peut marcher
finalement c'était des opportunités que
j'ai eus pardon parce que j'étais dans
la branche textile shirts et qu'ils sont
avec attractions fac tu es mon nom était
bientôt proposer mais c'est pas moi qui
des marchés le président jospeh moitié
l'effort des auditions mais oui je te
dirai honnêtement qui est
longtemps télécom le théâtre lactée
needs ça c'était comme un rêve un
produit mis de côté et loti fin qui est
pour ça que je me suis justement faire
des vidéos dans louis nous des trucs de
même c'est pas ça me permet d'incarner
des personnages puis j'aime beaucoup
seul souci j'aurai des opportunités puis
que ça convient la personne n'attend que
l'audition tout fonctionne encore qui
quel talent serait encore la maison mais
je dirais pas non je te fallu que c'est
justement parlé de trahison par les tic
toc c'est ce que ce que mettons pour
restituer au choix d'être ultra l'affût
des caisses qui pensent qu est-ce qui
multiplie est-ce qu'il fallut que tu
t'adaptes tout le temps son offre avec
l'élite les temps qui changent dans oui
mais je suis riche beau one pour face je
suis le genre quelqu'un dans ville en
général je peux bottes pourraient y dort
dans les tendances du moment
youtube souvent je planifie quand même
un peu mes vidéos d'avancé fx pour ce
secteur que j'avais bien l'âme âgées
comme je passais spontanée où j'ai pas
mes journées sont bookés d'avant ce
package pas capable vraiment de suivre
la cadence tant que mais avec les années
quand ça commence à être un peu plus de
torts sur youtube je me dis je voyais
que c'est comment dire mais il ya des
concepts en fait beauté qui ont marché
longtemps mettons des routines du matin
ou des favoris du mois que je me rendais
compte que le au hockey amener ça sa
poignée jusque là pendant huit ans des
baux puis le groupe le monde clic pudil
fac j'ai zélés signe un peu de se
renouveler mais moi ce que je trouve dur
particulièrement cdd se renouveler sans
dénaturer une grosse place de challenger
en 2016 2017 tout le monde faisait du
challenge and lifestyle fashion tv le
dois aussi c'est tellement de remise en
question et youtube avec ma maman mais
c'est ce qui est beau shoot que je
trouve qui sied aux dictats carrière de
deux créateurs de contenu on dirait que
tu fais vraiment un truc qui est aux
petites heures et audrey qui est comme
une joie des clips youtube à toutes ces
piges et pas la pression je vois tu fais
tes affaires cpa tamagna puis ça
vraiment eu un succès
un spa sur ses sens justement que tu as
eu besoin d'eux comme jouer la game tant
que je trouvais ça risque et le tir des
fautes de tavel challenge des colis
challenge maton qui panière ya quelques
années parce que des challenges que
toutes les histoires allaient reprendre
j'étais comme ans du fou tu fasses situe
le fait au début mais en même temps tu
étais ancien abonné aux autres a encore
ton plus de continuité avec ses tours
s'est trouvé la fine balance anjar faire
des nouveaux concepts pour attirer de
nouvelles personnes en même temps pas
des savoirs des abonnés de longue date
parce que pour vrai j'en ai quand même
pas mal des défis qui me suivent depuis
depuis le début on va dire typiquement
encore ce fac et annoncer tous les blogs
aussi chaussé du foie trouver des trucs
nouveaux lits classés comme les
coulisses de ta vie mais l'on n'en ont
pas démis fac est selon moi y'a rien
d'excitant montrer mais les abonnés
comme non vu des choses
c'est dingue tout âge à aller coûte puis
de temps en temps je pense prendre 10
pts tiré ce qu'il a essayé des nouveaux
concepts mais si c'est un concept que je
peux vraiment adapté aux machines
justement la surprise à mon abonné je me
dis ces gens d'affaires qui n'importe
qui peut regarder andrieu c'est une
vidéo make up mais c'est pour voir les
surprises qui contexte peu ce qui est tu
sais ça avoir d'intérêt pour le make up
je pense j'aimerais bien que beaucoup
d'influenceurs qui
c'est qui avec la plate forme avec le
following qui ont construit avait
sur des années des années le mettons
utilisent
ce bassin de monde mais pour se lancer
en affaires mettant le tpiy
l'enseigné et puis c'est tout c'est plus
facile parce que j'ai connu est-ce que
tout c'est une avenue que par sajoo
moyen moyen tout ça tout le temps été
pas mal plus une fin en soi que georges
fait se mettront pour être à la télé le
tient en haute estime et on leur cave de
finir animateur de télé mais moins
nettement sa jamais été seul fait que
moi c'est comme je vous ai tous deux
comme je suis ce que je fais mon bout de
chemin et puis je vois les opportunités
je poche pas opportuniste pour ouvrir
dans ville oui j'ai déjà pensé faire ma
marque de maquillage c'est pas un rêve
que cherry mettons en ce moment j'ai eu
des belles opportunités d'en passer et
j'ai sorti de livre une collection avec
bouclant une collection avec suse ou
mais coptes et j'ai adoré c'est le moi
j'adore des projets créatifs comme ça en
compagnie d'une marque ou peu importe là
mais non c'est sûr maintenant sortir de
ma marque je trouve que ce seras du
trotteur on trouve que trop tard ouais
mais pas au sens qu'est georges pense
que je ferais pas une scène avec ça mais
mais oui aussi un peu au sens où le
succès pour moi de la majorité des
youtube heurts qui ont commencé un peu
plus à mon époque c'était 2016 deux
messages c'était la folie furieuse
youtube c'est pas la folie furieuse mais
la folie jean le québec s'est réveillé
sur youtube sont avait démis top le
monde c'est là je pense pas qu'on aurait
nécessairement les mêmes rapports
l'utilisent nos abonnés ont grandi ici
notamment mais non c'est plus parce que
je voulais tellement de marques de
cosmétiques faisant douter mais oh mon
dieu c'est genre moi j'en reçois pour
tester puis je suis overworld comme il
ya des nouvelles marques et chaque jour
au pays des collections ça sent à chaque
semaine georges peut même petit pop avec
seul avec caisses qui sont accueillis
comme si je fais une mauvaise meetic
genre qu'est ce que je vais faire des
différents puis est-ce que ça va être
utilisé je le ferai pas juste pour la
forme et projet ça tout en un qui fait
parce que j'ai senti qu'il y avait un
manque ok c'est ce que je comprends la
chaîne youtube les livres c'est le
projet que je travaille pour le
printemps prochain on a peut-être juste
une parmi tant d'autres à rien de ce
soit déjà il ya un maudit bon flash lors
des deux concepts qui s'est pas vu mais
pour ces raisons le pigeon ces raisons
un peu écolo ça me tente plus produire
je comprends je comprends plus ce qui
est embêtant
c'est ce que tu veux pas faire quelque
chose qui te pas besoin dans le fond on
en a reçu geneviève elle rêve juste
avant tout aujourd'hui de cépie et reds
est cassée lens était en affaire parce
que vous les crises et à faire leur part
pour elle la voulait faire des sushis
tous ses amis au début le titre est
quelque chose qui manquait à elle j'ai
comme l'impression que c'est une bonne
façon de sites total n'a pas besoin
maintenant
si tu crois pas vraiment la pertinence
de ce secteur c'est dur de beaucoup sont
tombés sur le ticket qu'il veut pas de
l'argent pseudo zombies dans la vie ils
veulent faire et puis c'est quand même
assez juste moyenne à quelque chose
quand même un peu piteux machine à
claques la question écolo un temps les
choses d'un peu crise à moi quand je
regarde ce schéma ce que tu dis
2 comme un homme d'influencé qui lancent
des affaires quelque chose d'un peu
crise en jeu voire de la marge pour de
la merde
j'avais peur voici voici un t shirt
gildan déjà acheté j'ai aimé mon labo
dessus puis voici de la marge que le
vent après le monde à cause que j'ai une
tribune je trouve quelque chose dans le
bas non je suis on me le proposait
souvent le défendent ecolab comme x
mettons justement on a proposé entre
autres de faire une collection
d'articles écolo maintenant des choses
zéro déchet mais encore là bas avec moi
puis même si gentil puis je suis flatté
je sais pas si je vais voter je porte le
mouvement breton que cela maintenant le
papier c'est que si je fais une
collection même plus mon kit déco par
titre une collection 0 d'échapper à big
bang la vie de tous les jours peut pas
érodé shipshaw
je ne suis pas c'est juste que le monde
ne connaissent plus pour le maquillage
cercle mais ceux qui me suivent sa
chaîne de blogs qui ont vraiment comme
les coulisses de ma vie ils me
connaissent beaucoup mieux aussi mais
des trucs à mon effigie 2x magasins et
j'en ai des propos mais souvent ces
racistes devant la plus haute de faire
des collections de maquillage choix
seule femme nommée sinon
c'est pas ma peau mais ça non mais s'il
s'agit pas besoin non plus 6 à la fin
j'ai pas besoin de cet argent là non
plus pour éviter fax est vraiment
optionnel j ai 100% le choix c'est pas
tout temps des projets qui sont payants
non plus le tir non messieurs c'est en
fait c'est qu'au début ça on en avait
andréanne marquis sur le podcasting gtl
cette fine king lequel a eu deux par l
ag une tribune le monde paye pour que je
porte leur lance je veux porter le mien
oui puis à la lance son truc a vendu un
t-shirt la première semaine ne faut pas
tu le fasses pour le cash moi non je
sais j'avais trouvé ça intéressant
d'ailleurs ce podcast de montrer
vraiment les coulisses de
l'entrepreneuriat comme quoi ça y est
pris tellement de temps avant d'être
rentable dans le fond c'est souvent le
même le puits se lancer sa marque des
cosmétiques mois on m'avait dit si tu
peux faire ta marque ce genre des
milliers de
machines de recherche et développement
pour développer les productions trouver
les produits c'est moins cher de
s'associer avec une marque mais comme
j'avais déjà fait c'est une
collaboration avec studio make up que
j'avais adoré mais ça m'avait quand même
prouvé que dans le fond j'aurais aimé ça
par 100 % mon truc il fallut faire des
compromis sur certains produits moi je
trouvais avec tout mais ce but mais les
autres peut-être y avait un lancement
similaire qui seraient affolés fallait
faire les compromis non mais j'ai plus
j'étais personne qui m'a vraiment
approché pour faire ma marque non plus
j'ai pas démarcher fac c'est juste
jamais arrivé je pense pas que ça
maintenant chez que commenté sur
wii
le truc avec
back sur la vaccination a oui oui
j'oubliais j'oubliais entre ce qu'on a
fait ouais
jjp en
fait l'application sélective et puis on
va ramener des cosmétiques ladakh comme
de quoi y ait pu dire toi j'ai pas
beaucoup de législation mais ton par
rapport à ceux là dessus il y en a ce
sera serré les gens qui en est le 6 le
toit te réponde à ce propos
la cause exacte
puis c'est quoi dans le fond tu le
processus de création de cosmétiques
puis à quel point ce que toi dans ta
consommation de cosmétiques tout
intéresse
comment ça a été fait qu'est ce qui est
dedans pitt et parce qu'on parlait un
peu du grotte baleines pour les rouges à
lèvres qu'elle me suis toujours fait
j'entendais ça quand j'étais jeune moi
aussi mélange pas au courant qu'il sort
encore aujourd'hui le nom et c'est
souvent c'est que plus les gens pensent
que pas de réglementation puis que c'est
free for all c'est souvent c'est sur un
peu la façon que les gens parlent mais
c'est faux il y en a une réglementation
il y en a partout après tu entend
beaucoup dire par contre que celles en
europe et plus strictes et c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'ils ont les standards les
plus élevés mettons dans le monde par
rapport aux cosmétiques mais ça veut pas
dire que aux états unis on n'impose pas
souvent tentant et des phrases qui
reviennent souvent à temps sur les
médias sociaux comme quoi genre en
europe banis 1400 ingrédients versus 11
au canada s'est fait que ça fait peur
quand il dit ça comme ça mais quand tu
peux le contexte global c'est peut être
en fait c'est qu'elle manie de la
vitamine d sont sans qu'aucun produit
c'est exactement ça le point et le titre
du gosse d'avion dans la liste en europe
chez ducasse d'avion le ce quelqu'un
trouve un cosmétique et québécois qui se
gaussent d'avion des bandes dites moi
quel est ce que c'est pas parce qu'il y
ait pas dans la liste ici ces deux
façons en fait d'interpréter le
sait pas mais ici aussi ce règlement t
on au juste à taper sur google on tombe
vite de dites sur le site de santé
canada pts et voit les ingrédients qui
sont bannis des cosmétiques ou est sous
surveillance et tous ces mecs pas c'est
pas parfait mais y en ait une
réglementation pièce que c'est dur de
consommer éthique dans le monde du
maquillage ou bah
ouais c'est ça ce n'est pas quelques
retards en jeu j'ai été clair je pense
que chaque personne a son système de
valeurs dans le fond puis sa liste des
trucs à cocher fait que c'est dur de ces
pour ce moi j'aime ça je resterai multi
marques comme ceux j'essaye d'en donner
un peu à tout le monde mais ton le après
c'est moi c'est ma conclusion le
téléphone s'ils sont liés avec est ce
qu'on parle j'ai fait une série
documentaire il ya quelques mois ce
printemps en fait ce qui s'appelle
derrière les cosmétiques je pense que
vous avez vu mais si je mènerai avec ce
plan
c'est un peu ça ma conclusion c'est
qu'il ya tellement de choses c'est
quelqu'un peut vouloir acheter local
peut vouloir consommer bio dans tecos
métiers qui recrutent ifri vegan comme
on a dit tu peux te peut-être une peau
sensible tout y'a plein de marques qui
te convient de poser qui est tellement
de variétés c'est tellement large les
cosmétiques que genre si je doit cocher
tout les cas je vais parler de marque
disais ça marche comme paul et fac moi
sur ma conclusion c'est vraiment qui est
donc mon critère premier c'est
l'efficacité d'un produit parce que je
veux que si j'en recommande un produit
le monde les aime c'est après si ça
convient pas parce qu'il dit parfum de
d'un bep de touba de l'eau sens où je
vais parler d'autres produits qui vont
convenir à mener mais le monde entre
août 6h à 15h leurs attentes envers un
cosmétique je peux pas me mais réduira
genre je suis parler des accessibles les
tic en cosmétique il ya vraiment
plusieurs paliers est ce qu'on met
l'environnement l'admettons ce qu'on met
la santé des travailleurs et des parfums
concept qui pas accessible aux puits les
clés c'est utile des marques que tout
refuse de collaborer avec les autres de
représenter parce que toutes les
problématiques quelques-uns
aucune en particulier mais ça va
toujours dépendre du contexte mais dont
il vient de marquer québécoise qu'on ne
meurent pas qu'il m'avait offert il ya
quelques mois des de parler de leurs
produits et de les re tester j'avais
déjà un petit peu testé j'en ai parlé
sur mon blog et tout mais ils m'ont
écrit c'est le lendemain d'une
controverse impliquant la personne à la
tête de cette entreprise là oui donc non
le tee shirt rouge et or je vais poser
moto parce que c'est la personne qui
représente cette marque là des propos
que je juge erronés ou même dangereux si
je veux non je voudrais pas m'associer
avec seul mais sinon moi je dis tout a
été bien wheeling de tester tout ce
qu'on m'envoie pas contents les petites
marques québécoises qui se lancent des
cosmétiques naturels que genre lancôme
l'oréal peu importe je reçois gts quand
c'est waou gens parlent peu puis comme
ça mes abonnés y achète des trucs ils
sont comment merci parce que c'était bon
effectivement telle est mon idée c'est
comme un peu de police en gaspiller leur
argent dans les produits qui marchent
peut on ne serait pas écolo non plus tu
sais c'est que là c'est ça
mais c'est
j'imagine quand même parce que c'est
tough un certain temps à se retrouver
pour les consommateurs sont extrêmement
marqué tellement d'amour puis plein de
choses qu'on 6 po au québec - chanteuse
pour ce que j'ai fait le documentaire
aussi chanter quand il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qu'on était juste beau
courageuse même si moins cher que dix
ans chez dans le domaine qui j'étais pas
au courant de tout je demande à mes amis
étaient pas au courant non plus le fait
que non ces sites c'est très flou tian
et qu'ils me demandent plus de
transparence aux marques il y en a qui
ont peur de le faire et c'est parce que
ça peut leur rebond très facilement dans
la face il y en a qui commence à le voir
de plus en plus enfin qui s'essayait
toutes sortes de courants dans les
cosmétiques toutes sortes de croyances
ou six qui circulent puis
quelqu'un comme toi même ton outré par
son mentor ce que je sais pas quel point
de prendre des positions
parce que nous mettons une jeune fille
qui va commencer à se maquiller
je vais sûrement prendre les produits
que tu parle parce que je veux pas moi
avoir le temps de toutes les essayer
maintenant que tu dis que la nôtre ont
préféré je vais l'acheter lui le sait
sauf que ce pour toi est une position
qui est quand même rohff parce que si tu
poche en lan qui ton prof qui est une
compagnie x le ça devient comme un peu à
cordes avec les autres compagnies tu
voudrais potentiellement collaborer plan
éthique bien précieux c'est comme
essayer de séparer qu'est-ce qui est un
qui commande c'est sûr que tu mentionnes
sûr que tu mets ton même pour une
compagnie comme entité béton moi je
regarde la vidéo puis je te prends
prétention tu fais sûrement podium et
peut-être mais en fait le consommateur
ne sait pas est ce que maintenant la
vidéo qui est sponsorisée tout ça c'est
vraiment la bombe sera la bonne un jeu
type a commencé je reprends ton opinion
sur l'équipe a commenté mettons la en
tant que consommateur parce que j'en
fasse l2 c'est sûr que c'est pas assez
pas fait dire parle de ce produit
leridon laitiers ces gens ça deviendrait
difficile à jongler je pense que mes y
en eut que même le fait que je reçoive
des produits gratuitement ils vont
remettre en doute mon jugement
la quantité que je reçois par semaine
j'ai aucunement peur de faire mettons
review plus négatif que la marque arrive
de m'envoyer des produits loge mais je
parlais mise acheter
une commandite vous restez impôts une
vidéo sponsors j'ai pas aimé le truc non
s'était jamais un nombre de points mais
le truc non mais non mais je teste avant
pour moi les apports par ceux ci leur
dit non je ne veux pas
ça me fait ch qui apportera plus calme
en disant tout les influenceurs on a
déjà fait ça de pousser les produits
qu'on est moche comme pour bien pour ma
part non non non parce que ma
crédibilité mais charges oblige les
acquis érige acquérir la confiance des
gens depuis dix ans ça va se savoir
assez vite si je fais juste accepté de
l'argent pour d'argent piqué jeu
promouvoit n'importe quoi juste parce
que c'était payant seulement parce
qu'ils me font confiance pour qu'ils
achètent les produits souvent le bien
souvent
ils finiraient par sa rencontre qui
n'était pas si bon que j'ai pas
confiance et de la grosse merde
non non c'est sûr je te mettrai pas que
ça peut être tentant pour cissé des
montants qui sont allées shopping parce
que ces compagnies là ils y ont de
larges jeunes ayant de l'argent c'est
hyper lucratif honnêtement ça coûte pas
si cher que ça avant le métier petit
voile et marc cosset programme et on
sait tous que quand chara produire
message et
georges payet comme un instant d'or qui
s'est élevé avec le temps là dessus
quand j'ai commencé tôt les petites
marques de pharmacie nanana pleut les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui mettons unis
commencent à magasiner mettons ces
forêts le fait que le monde sont prêts à
mettre plus dans un produit si ça vaut
la peine aussi un coup de coeur mais
ouais je comprends ta question sais je
sais que ça peut être très mélange tout
j'ai travaillé avec avec des bannières
qui vendre plusieurs marques oui moi
même temps et des pharmacies moi c'est
sûr que maintenant je suis un gars qui
fait des review de souliers de course à
pied puis à chaque fois qu'un nouveau
soulier peu importe la marque qui sort
il en parle preview qui donne son
opinion en est après avoir couru tue 50
kilos tire puis puis lui travaille avec
une boutique de course à pied prix 20
tout les modèles fait qu'il ya comme pas
vraiment de de parti pris dans les
compagnies comme tel quand la
fiction tout à fait parce que ça semble
être une avenue qui est vraiment
intéressant parce que là qu'on comprend
la bannière c'est le fun pour réseau
weebe promouvoir leurs produits
moi c'est sûr c'est comme un peu oui un
type de partenariat rêver au sens où
c'est le fun car une marque c'est arrivé
récemment le lancement je rencontre avec
une de ses marques lucky monde y veille
c'est quoi tes coups de coeur chez nous
qui parle de ses coups de coeur le
bonheur dure non mais une marque
maintenant une marque je peux le dire je
pense laisser l'irak l'irak qui voulait
révéler travailler avec moi puis j'avais
déjà testé certains grands produits pour
tous mais ils m'ont dit tu parles de tes
coups de coeur fait que les produits que
je pousse comme de temps en temps le x1
thermale son nom et sa gamme mais vrai
coup de coeur pas sinon je t'avoue que
généralement c'est plus qu'une marque
fine campagne autour d'un lancement il
faut c'est un vieux produit mais soit se
peloter nouveautés puis le yes pas à
trouver quelqu'un qui va accepter d'en
parler c'est souvent c'est ça c'est plus
comme tu le test puis voici tulle m
après je comprends qu'ils demandent
peuvent douter de la sincérité du monde
qui ont fait comme un ben oui je l aime
se passe quand
il y en a qui le font mais c'est pour ça
je me trouve chanceux je sais que j'ai
choix de dire non il y en a qui l'on
promettait ces dates sont à chaque mois
de youtube donc sont obligés un peu de
prendre des placements de produits pour
mais j'ai le choix j'ai le choix face à
un beau bonus mais j'ai le choix
mais c'est cool tant mieux soit le seuil
d au moins tu peux respecter tu peux
rester dans ton est resté fidèle à 6,6
pendant un mois il ya aucun contre je
m'en fous je verrai
ça n'en prend moutadit des écoutes pour
pour vivre deux absences ouailles c'est
maintenant commenté vidéo font en
moyenne mais chic ça a changé il a
maintenant à maintenant parce qu'il faut
que tu ailles un nombre d'heures
sur le tas et coûté que soit le nombre
des côtes ouais c'est ça mais comme
nathan si vous vous êtes éligible à la
monétisation si vous faites en bois
et la question
c'était oui sa moyenne est maintenant en
mode il dort jamais la face et que c'est
tellement compliqué à 100 a expliqué
parce que lui et ses pairs ne sont pas
égales d'une personne à l'autre moi ce
que j'ai su avec le temps les gens
récemment c'est que je suis peut-être
dans un bon créneau aussi parce qu'étant
à plein des pubs maquillage maquillage
machine maquillage et comme et dans un
créneau fièvre des pubs spécialement mes
côtés mais si tu parles de lifestyle
justement ma chaîne devrait guêpe à ce
sujet précis mais
je
t'avoue jeter [ __ ] trop les stars ça
me gênait rubin tron a accepté un
certain humour le fait que j'essaye
d'éviter d'arriver vous savez youtube
studio le départ il dit c'est quoi la
performance dans la vidéo j'ai dit
ok je sais depuis trop checker ce petit
jeu reçoit le montant que je reçois la
fin du mois de mai mais non c'est sur la
chaîne développe j'aurais passé de vue
le thé souvent j'ai vingt mille vu
trente mille vu par le fait que ce
serait pas assez pour vivre mais la
chaîne beauté ça tout un des plus 50000
vu en montant facture on en met en cap
par mois se rend compte qu'un perdant
vie mais il ya des mois meilleur cadeau
ici à 100 c'est quand même c'est ça
dépend comment me trompe de vue c'est
pas ce système reste que je tends
revenus conséquents moi moi moi c'est
mon salaire
à tous qui toute l'année est un peu un
peu pour ajoutez à cela les contres
genre quand je fais des contrats avec
des compagnies si j'en fais surtout plus
qu'un par mois maintenant c'est vraiment
plus payant 400
agents sont revenus de la finale va être
plus oui ça fait un peu plus gros
morceau quand c'est les marques mais
pareil qui depuis des années que à
chaque mois je suis correct léoty je
vais avoir assez d'argent à 100 pour
payer tout ce que j'ai à payer donc
hypothèque etc ont bien mieux lotis
j'aime poser cette question là parce que
parce que je me pose à moi - jeu
constamment mais gbagbo dans un
chat is the question je sais pas je
laisse passer tellement hâte afin
répondre sauf qu'en même temps j'aime ça
me dit je vis au jour le jour quand même
temps j'aime aussi samedi taille que
j'aimerais prendre une bonne direction
maintenant pour que c'est là la tendance
soit bonne jusque dans dix ans c'est
parce que mettons un degré de différence
aujourd'hui ce grand chose mais déjà le
degré devient loin
non pouvais je sais pas quand ce que je
sais pas où ça s'envoie qu'il a accepté
que je trouve cette question de se la
poser ou d'y penser mais je pense qu
autrefois y voyez côté des plus jeunes
quand j'étais ado mettons je pensais
tout le temps à l'avs n'est vraiment
vraiment puis est arrivée des événements
qui m'ont forcée plus à vivre le moment
présent que je ressens vraiment moyen
que ces jeunes vivent au maire présent
passer pour celui qu'on leur enseigne la
méditation et
fakih et non c'est non je pense pas trop
que ce soit était ma vie professionnelle
et ma vie amoureuse n'importe quoi je
change plus au jour le jour toute
confiance que tu t'adaptes rire danser
rêver de quad qui essaient mettons les
algorithmes sont incomplètes n'y avait
plus d'argent en forme et on sur
internet tu confiance que ça va mal et
plutôt adapté
au cinéma question plutôt tu es
maintenant
quand tu vis que seulement méthode est à
100 sous 2 dudit réseau ce soit leurs
critiques en
revanche à la merci de publier public
mettait les remercie de la compagnie de
l'algorithme qui se ça peut changer puis
ça change changement d'arbitré amani
peut-être que justement il pour extraire
dont il y aura plus d'argent mais ton
affaire avec instagram
qui sur les questions de têtu glace et
un match nul quelque chose qui est
plus à ton pouvoir plutôt qu'à être un
sujet d'une plateforme comprend des ben
oui c'est ça s'arrête une bonne idée
maintenant la marque pour seul comme à
long terme sont où mais j'ai aussi
d'autres projets qui est bon pour
l'instant continue encore de vivre
d'entente justement les livres t on à
des royautés à chaque année les autres
enseignes et bien sûr mais ton et j'ai
aussi mon blog mais ton qui m'appartient
la fin qui est plus j'utilise plus avec
moi parce que c'est trop long face du
contenu partout ailleurs le fait que je
fais mes articles des blogs qui me
prenait 1,5 en découlent mais si j'aurai
encore ce puits comme c'est le pire
coccyx et les médias sociaux ça marche
pas comme je dis je reviendrai à mon
scénario initial de maquilleuses ou si
ça me tente plus à ce moment le parce
que je t'avoue ce soit le salaire serait
plus le même du tout si je reviens à
faire des contrôles maquillage surtout
que j'aurais pas d'âge ans puis je
réponds bien chargé pour un make up et
l'histoire explorer d'autres avenues
comme on dit tantôt peut-être comédienne
ou est sinon j'ai un gros intérêt pour
les plantes fake horticultrice ait nommé
sujets d'intérêt pour les plantes oui
oui jardine beaucoup
ouais ça on le voit plus la chaîne
développe même sur instagram j'ai créé
l'autre un autre un autre compte du
jardinage oh wow et parce que je me
trouvais cassandre de parler de plan de
total pour les gens qui me pose ce matin
avec le gie juste des aborigènes feu
dans ce sujet lire sur cette plateforme
hub c'est vraiment le choix tactiques
peut-être si j'habitais un changement de
carrière ça pourrait être soulevée ça se
passe dans le milieu des hommes et c'est
quelque chose que j'aime bien fait que
c'est toujours des workshops lors des
ateliers des trucs tu faisais un peu de
cours de maquillage avant la pandémie là
un petit peu j'en faisais au manoir mais
c'était juste que mon emploi du temps me
le permettait
rien de rien d'un grosse et puis j'aime
ça mais pour cent pour cent n'ont plus
le temps passe que dans le temps
maintenant je recevais le monde chez
nous le pilon temps j'allais fait même
que je t en aparté que youtube était
commencée depuis un bon bout de temps je
recevais légère chez nous
ou dont je ne sais pas j'ai arrêté de le
faire mais c'est sûr ça serait le fun de
tanger rien le qualité installons
rencontre je pourrais rester le petit
monstre bouche post le à chaque fois
refaire ma trousse en éponge sur sa
fiche ouais
l'automne ta maison tu es un con duire
maison maison d'emile quatre ans
avec une quête qui
d'un ton set up chez vous dans une pièce
pour ça un bureau bureau sage gardera
puis un studio que ses deux fils plein
maquis à
chaque fois ci ça c'est parce que je
reçois des envois qui était pas
nécessairement désir et le fait que vos
chances de boxing faut que j'aie trice
et du tri constant qui ont mené ces
sites web plus clair là dedans faudrait
pourtant que je fasse du ménage jean
mont speke a donné ça déborde c'est sûr
c'est beaucoup de gestion saviez tout
avec des emails aussi ces envois leur
fac ça me fait mal boîte de réception
jamais bon de toiture sont
les envoyais des produits gratuits si
jamais les agents mais rarement les
agences qui chasse
d'autant que mon agent il faisait juste
l'egypte agence le manager juste donner
une
réponse
intelligente il s'engage pas en parler
ou tu publies sais pas non moi je pense
ça serait trop prenant la pauvre et
chaque samedi
mais comme cette tragédie est tout un
make up des soins qui sortent juste ça
fait trop de l'agencé autres ça leur
rapporte annoncé ce projet
les contrastes en mars
même passion pour le make up qui est
avait volé dix ans ou le s'est rendu
plus un job dit oui oui mais je pensais
que j'allais demander c'est plus par
rapport aux produits se jeta vous la
première fois comment envoyer un colis
pioche du genre oh my god
oui ce texte m comme des fois c'est
parce que souvent les produits que je
vais sûrement faire klochkova c'est de
la gestion je me plains la bouche pleine
parce que
des cosmétiques gratuity moi je n'achète
jamais jamais jamais jamais aucun
produit puis je fournis
mais c'est ce saviez vous savez qu'une
certaine pression parce que justement tu
veux pas de décevoir les marchés c'est
ça leur coûte trop cher et envoyées sont
entamées sait jamais quand il va pouvoir
retravailler avec une de ses marques là
mais pourtant question tantôt yapo trop
de compétition entre les marques c
sérums et ont conquis vont demander pour
des l'exclusivité
derniers sponsors sur youtube s'il y
avait un produit qui était mis de
l'avant mais dans la vidéo je parlais
déjà sans mes cent mille autres marques
le fait que ça l'aide alors j'ai pas
trouvé ça parce que les créateurs beauté
et en ce moment ce serait l'horreur est
ambassadeur genre d'une marque le jeu le
post je vais vraiment pas ce fait qu'ils
sont habitués que tout le monde va
travailler avec une marque qui empêche
pas l'occulter c'est bien normal qu'on
aime des marques différentes dans le
make-up le camp c'est ta passion petit
et ce topic découvert jeudi des trucs
était tellement polémique besoin d'en
parler mais temps de faire une revue
négative
c'est ça c'était un de mes
questionnements récemment mettons parce
que c'est ainsi je faisais des vidéos
premières impressions format hdtv parce
que c'était plus simple plus rapide sur
mon blog puis le monde est déjà le hand
que j'aime mieux faire selon qui des
fois maintenant je testais un mascaret
l'autre semaine qui était pas bon
faculté comme ces plates un peu au sens
où le monde vont se taper dix minutes
deux premières impressions pour se
rendre compte que c'est pas bon vivre ce
moment pas l'acheter en même temps c'est
sincère je m'étais je me demandais
c'était pertinent de faire une vidéo que
j'ai fait voter les gens mais ce n est
pas fini fifty fifty et il y en a qui me
plaît vraiment quand même voir le
pourquoi ya pas fonctionné mais lorsque
la conclusion la date c'est plus que je
vais faire jean juste une petite heure y
mettant ses produits ajustés pour
trouver mais voici pourquoi puis voilà
tu sais je recommande pas du tout mais
je vais jamais jean bacci quand les
produits c'est justement je reprends
l'exemple du bien qui commentent les
souliers de course ouais ça m'épate à
bar mc alger que sa vidéo de 15 minutes
au complet puisque la cei il parle du
soulier mais y aborde toutes les vidéos
de la même façon c'est plein mais il
parle de quelque chose puis jazz si je
m'appelais donner des notes sur
plusieurs aspects le tarif est bleu le
sujet finalement signé deux jours
disputée à 15 minutes d'un soulier que
cela ne va jamais acheté le tout avis
net parce que lui défection de la série
préférée semaine historique bakou genre
que nous nommons nationale lorimer jarre
le titre ces genres et by the way
s'essuyer les 210 si vous voulez voir
pourquoi quiconque tue sinon mettons le
suit huit sur dix soit à checker richard
couaillet ya pas de déposer ce projet
palestinien j'avoue je préfère ce parce
que les cta france cgt cosop le tout au
long de ces même tu sais pas trop si je
suis bon point parce que l'udc en suisse
en libye où il est déjà testé le mois 7
en six manches résister comme pour
mémoire la première fois j'ai le même et
je te dis qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent
comme je faisais sur mon blog jeunes
full full foule de détails le par
rapport au produit mais que le monde
sache que vraiment qu'est ce qu'ils
achètent match puis pour revenir à la
question que tout oppose et entonne le
de répondu pour mettons tout ce qui est
recevoir les produits les produits qui
maintenant fait partie d'adjamé attend
encore le feu sacré pour le maquillage
mais willam écosse est jugée vraiment
d'autres passions aussi une envie là des
fois le monde y mette vraiment d'accord
ce maquillage est comme jésus je me
souviens pinceau jardiner matos mais
mais oui on est vachement très beau
temps à parler d'eux non non non c'est
non je suis pas tanné je suis un peu
tanné
les défis à long terme c'est plus de
pouvoir répétés des trucs mais encore
lundi matin j'avais déjà fait parking
day d'une vidéo sur les types de peau
puis là je leur fais parce que dans
pandémie le monde se sont vraiment moins
maquillée mais ils ont commencé à
s'intéresser plus au skin care puis je
suis de nouveau si des plus jeunes qui
commencent à tuer cinq univers on peut
la vidéo de ie8 en fait j'en ai fait une
c à jour puis ça a vraiment bien marché
que le fait qu'il ya des concepts qui se
retrouveront mais moi je sais un autre
personnage mpo voudrait faire dix fois
la même affaire n importe quoi fait que
c'est plus ça à long terme comment je
vais faire mais graduellement j'essaye
de trouver quelle forme de contenu je
préfère faire ou tipi justement comme le
je me disais aux tic tac je pense va
marcher sur le donc concertés sur les
huiles un sayan bonne idée plus de
plaisir
non mes vacances et à écrire j'ai à vous
devriez peut-être personnes qui ont leur
sujet va casser genre ouais c'est bien
son nom à côté saint fils tu te
retrouves et pascal comment ça va
même si on me demande souvent les vidéos
que j'ai déjà des salaires s'ils sont
encore à jour
et des choses de est il maintenant il y
avait quelqu'un médias sont très bon que
je fasse une vidéo sur comment la vie
ses pinceaux parce que je sais pas trop
si c'est comme un truc de base qui est
indémodable fatiguée de me refaire un
petit événement là dessus
ce qui s'en vient d'effectuer dans les
prochains prochains mois prochain non à
court terme c'est ça ma prochaine vidéo
que j'ai période de beau jeu qu'avaient
qu'il faut que je montre cette semaine
et ça j'ai vraiment hot et non sinon
pour vrai nom si je continue ou la vie
dont naîtra ben oui puis un projet
secret mais qui pour l'année prochaine
un projet secret
des collabos qu'on a parlé tantôt en
plus qu'un truc qui existaient pas au
salon bois sur le marché
ouais on ait dit
ça peut vraiment crimes sexuels
ok moi je vais tout ça ça vous mélangez
les gens mais c'est vrai paraissait un
autre projet que je fais avec ma maison
d'édition
d'autres plats qu'ils soient personnels
ou un voyage ou
[Rires]
dans celle avec la pandémie non j'ai
vraiment pas de plats
trop cher
c'est dommage mais non j'ai un spécial
facs et les vidéos puis jardinage qui
j'étais au jardinage mais la vie
continue
ça fait longtemps que j'en dis non sa
passion
c'est comme dans un film j'avais tout
comme la maison le geler tout on l'a
tout rénover les corps et puis après ce
bain si seule la passion des plantes
d'intérieur s'est transposée en plantes
d'extérieur
j'avais que j'avais plein d'idées plein
de place pour m'amuser avec ab rien
qu'en charvet ou des choses que j'aime
et que j'ai enlevé et puis cela s'est
beaucoup de jobs je fais cette source
mais j'aime vraiment ça sais-tu potager
où c'est plus fleurs les deux et un
petit potager le pot énorme je me fais
des bacs surélevés l'année passée fac là
on en est officiel le mais sinon moi et
moi ses plus plates bandes de plus les
fleurs mon intérêt principal a déjà créé
tout âge de tout acheter des nouvelles
vives faire des dépôts massifs
mais dessus des études et youtube a
lancé
au québec
non mais c'est pour ça justement je me
sens par le
fait que le monde juste moi je me dis
aux autres s'ils doivent pas avoir des
bienfaits tio tio marque laverda qui est
vraiment connu sur facebook puis a fait
aussi des vidéos sur youtube et son
métier l'a fait qu'à donne des bons
conseils pour avoir ce mais justement
d'autres chaînes y développe genre de
jardinage ya beaucoup de chaînes mettant
sur les potagers en france en anglais
maintenant je suis gordon en turquie est
vraiment populaire le tas plus qu'un
million d'abonnés et puis est aux états
unis à jardy dans leur intérêt
incroyable genre immense mais au québec
et ou en français jean crépin taxi way
imagine image si jean martin fortes y
faisait un blog c'est une fois par
semaine il parle de ce
genre une journée dans la vie de match
il y passe christiane oui je parlais
suivi est agressée certe mais là c'est
plus ce genre et sa business plan et qui
pousse l'homme et c'est maintenant
vraiment un maraîcher qui fait un genre
c'est ça le blog car le tutoriel le cam
a fait pousser des poivrons rouges
courbe est bien connu sur tic tac
d'ailleurs tu fais ça oui sur youtube
ses seins français ouaki au québec je
peux parce que si on ne gênerait que les
gens le disent dans les commentaires
on lance la perche dans l'ansé vous
oui en plus depuis la pandémie le
jardinage aouissi sa maison ça a été un
des packs as
vraiment tous l'écouté de l'écouté
c'est
vraiment un juge comment ça marche
criquetot bio loris imiter peut-être que
ça va mal aimé l'écouter dans la dans le
métro à retourner chez nous
et
merci infiniment
dalphond fait justement qu'on close
charlotte à des plateformes et ces sites
adultes par thouars le fait que
mouhssine celle de l'autre vlog mettons
sur youtube puis instagram est mon blog
maquillage unsa points comme mais je
l'entretiens puis comme un petit stock
dessus mais jugeait plus certain
sagamie auto plus merci beaucoup merci
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin des sports que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup si vous voulez avoir
plus de contenus plus de conversations
sur pétillante que ça se passait sur p
tu es un non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce
qu'on les tombes donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pga mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde p tu n es qu on
parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi de la
conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur notre patrie turenne et le
lien vers ce havre dans la description
du podcast qui remercie encore une fois
de nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin